I recently we've been getting an amazing
response to this every cently issued a
challenge to our viewers to try to see
if they could watch the show and find a
mistake we make on the program yeah
that's right my good look yeah now a fan
thinks he found a mistake okay he posted
a video on YouTube where he objects to
the way I described that Cobra that
escaped from the Bronx Zoo let's take a
look
hi Kenan I noticed on your show on March
30th that you were talking about the
snake that escaped from the Bronx Zoo a
poisonous snake went missing at the
Bronx Zoo over the weekend you say it
the snake was poisonous when there were
no such thing as poisonous snakes there
are only venomous snakes so I thought
that I would point it out to you thank
you okay well anyway we don't know this
fans name no we could make up a name for
like Don Juan just listen you know what
he thinks he's right well this is easy
to settle here now to answer that
question is the Cobra from the Bronx Zoo
now which one are you are you poisonous
or venomous ah come on venomous no one
in the Bronx says venomous come on a
poisonous what do I look like a fairy
huh hey kid I got you a venomous right
here Yeah right here where I'm pointing
I know you don't you don't have a crotch
so don't do that I'm all crotch baby now
shut up
[Applause]
100% crotch I don't know why is that
what a Cobra from the bronze no I mean
he was little he was so closed lit
during the first act I know yeah you had
to play anyway if you think you've
spotted an error on our show I guess
that makes me six for six so fast all
right if you think you've spotted an
error on our show report it at team
koco.com slash ha ha I found an error we
will sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the maestro we'll
be right back Greg Kinnear is here